[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROMAN: Hello there.
Welcome once again to Android
Design in Action.
I'm your host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM: Hey guys.
It's Adam [INAUDIBLE].
And over in London we have--
NICK: Nick Butcher, hi.
ROMAN: So today we have a
special episode dedicated
entirely to the action
bar design pattern.
We unfortunately don't have
any redesigns to do today.
We're not going to look
at any specific apps.
But we will talk in depth
about the action bar.
So with that I guess we
should jump right in.
Because we have lot of content
to go through.
Adam, do you want to
kick things off?
ADAM: Yeah, sure.
So one quick thing before
we get started, Nick may
potentially be coming through
on one audio channel only.
So if you've got one earbud in,
maybe switch the other one
if you can't hear him.
ROMAN: In case you can't.
ADAM: In case you cant,
potentially.
NICK: If you can't hear this.
ADAM: So let's get started.
We want to do a deep dive on the
action bar today, so the
action bar.
I've got a couple of quotes here
from the design guide.
I'm just going quickly
read them out.
The action bar is a dedicated
piece of real estate at the
top of each screen that is
generally persistent
throughout the app.
And second quote, which I
actually like better--
the action bar is one of the
most important design elements
you can implement and will go
a long way toward make your
app's interface consistent with
the core Android apps.
So I think people ask,
why should I
implement the action bar?
I'd rather go off and do some
other design pattern.
I think consistency is just
really, really important.
So that when users pick up
your application, they
instantly know how to use it.
Because they're so used
to the system apps.
So it's just a really, really
important design pattern.
If you've been listening to
show, and hopefully you've
been looking at the design
side, hopefully you
already know this.
ROMAN: Yeah, and the action
bar, through all of the
designs that we've done
ourselves, we've always
included an action bar.
There are some cases where an
action bar, it may not be,
necessarily.
For example, Google Now does
not actually have an action
bar at its top level screen.
But if you notice, once you get
into the detail screens,
once you get to the setting
screen or things that, there
is an action bar.
So there's some kind of
edge cases where you
may not need one.
But almost certainly,
99% of the time you
should include one.
NICK: I consider this one
of those cases of
deviate with purpose.
Unless there's a really good
reason, you probably want to
be using one.
ADAM: Definitely.
Let's move along here.
So the general organization--
again hopefully you're familiar
with this already.
But we just thought we'd cover
it again, the basics.
So on the left portion of the
action bar, you have your
navigational elements.
And then on the right
side, the action.
So it's pretty clearly split
between the two sides.
I think that it's a very
important to follow, this
general layout.
If you do decide to deviate in
some way, shape, or form, you
should just always keep
this in mind.
And try and stick to this
if you possibly can.
ROMAN: And actually, one minor
comment, I think in earlier
versions of Honeycomb the search
button in some apps was
actually on the left.
And then we moved that over
to the right as an action.
Because it was really just
a more common place.
And we really wanted to
standardize as search being an
action, rather than a
navigational element.
It can be portrayed--
if you think about it logically,
you can probably
argue either way for search.
But certainly the platform
convention is to
keep it as an action.
ADAM: So we've got a bit more
detail here on the general
organization of the
action bar.
A very, very important
piece, the app icon.
So here you've got your
branding, your identity.
And also it gives you a sense
of place, with this "up"
affordance that shows
when you're not at
the top level screens.
So personally I think people
should always take advantage
of the branding piece of this.
Not only because it tells the
user which application they're
in when they're using it.
But also, if they love the app,
they're going to start to
identify that branding with
your application.
Next time they're flicking
through their home screen, or
in their all apps list, they'll
see that icon there.
And they'll be, hey, I haven't
used that app in a while.
And I really, really
like that app.
And they'll come back to it.
So I think this it's
really important.
Sometimes I see people do custom
implementations or a
custom kind of action
bar, but they don't
include that branding.
Personally, I feel very strongly
that it's important.
NICK: One variation on that I'd
like to mention here is
that, quite commonly your
application might have a
single accent color,
which you strongly
associate with that brand.
So [INAUDIBLE]
might be pink, for example,
and so forth.
So there's also the opportunity
to take that
accent color as your action
bar color all together.
And in that case, I think it
works really, really nicely to
have a differentiated logo
from your app icon.
So it's entirely plausible
absolutely encouraged to have
a different launcher icon that
you might have in the launch
tray than the icon which appears
in the top left of the
action bar.
So you might go for
an inverted color.
Or maybe a single white
simplified version of your
icon, and then use the branding
color as the actual
background of the action bar,
rather than having it compete
with the same color.
ROMAN: As long as the core icon
itself is the same, as
long as the shapes and the forms
are really kind of the
same thing as the launcher
icon, you can
definitely do that.
ADAM: And of course, the YouTube
app does this, with
its launcher icon being
different to the action bar
app icon up there.
ROMAN: And actually, I think
they use a logo, as well.
So you don't necessarily have
to use an icon there if you
have enough horizontal space
available where you don't need
other items, like
view controls.
You can absolutely show
a wider version.
For developers, that's called
the Android colon logo for the
action bar.
But both the icon and the
logo, those should be
sufficient to convey
the branding.
NICK: And it works
really well.
Say you have one natural
homepage, like a newsfeed, or
[INAUDIBLE], which is the
natural home of the content,
you might want to provide
greater branding.
Like say a larger logo, which
takes up more width.
And then on subsequent pages,
you might want to cut that
back down to a square aspect
ratio icon, which will give
you more room to display
some title
information or view control.
ADAM: Exactly, and that segues
perfectly into the second part
of the action bar, which
is the control.
It can be used for navigation,
something like a spinner.
But also as Nick mentioned, it
can be used for a title of the
particular screen, as well.
ROMAN: The view control
also encompasses tabs.
So in some cases, especially
in phones--
and we'll talk about this
in a bit-- but tabs
can go in that area.
But in some cases they actually
drop into a second
lower area, below that action
bars, as a stacked version.
But tabs, spinner, and title,
we consider those view
controls, things that let you
see information about the
current context, the current
screen, as well as potentially
tweak things.
Like change perspective, or the
label, or something that
you're looking at.
ADAM: And then, as you
mentioned, on right side
you've got your actions.
So you've got your action
buttons there.
In this case, there's a search
and a record video action,
followed by what we call the
action overflow menu.
So this is where less frequently
used actions can be
collapsed into an overflow menu
that's not always visible
on the screen.
ROMAN: And very importantly for
the overflow, there are
also some platform conventions
on what things
should always go there.
So if you have application
settings, as well as Help and
About, Terms of Service, things
like that should go in
the overflow.
You shouldn't make those
immediately on screen, unless
something like Settings is the
number one use case for your
app, life if everybody is just
tweaking the settings.
But I'd say again, 99% of the
cases overflow should contain
settings as well.
ADAM: Moving along.
NICK: Is it worth mentioning
about the overflow, then--
sorry, just before
you do move on.
ADAM: No, go for it.
NICK: If we're talking about the
case of devices which have
a physical menu button, then
the overflow button won't
necessary display.
Because you're going to rely on
that physical affordance,
rather than the onscreen
affordance.
ADAM: Yep, good point.
And I think we have a screen
shot later on to
show how that works.
NICK: Oh, jumping the gun.
Sorry.
ADAM: No worries.
So the other nice thing about
the action bar is it's very
good at adapting to different
screen sizes, rotations,
actually the width
of the screen.
It's very, very good at
adapting to that.
So it does a few things to help
with the variation in
screen sizes.
And actually, I think it's
the next slide--
one particular thing that you
can do is engage this mode
called medical split
action bar mode.
And actually, from a developer
standpoint, it's a flag called
split action bar when narrow.
So it says, when the screen with
gets down to a certain
point, we're going to
go into this split
action bar mode instead.
So in split action bar mode,
you've got three potential
different bars that
you can have here.
You've got the main action
bar at the top.
You've got the top bar, which
Roman was talking about
before, is where the tabs could
potentially fall down to.
And then at the bottom of the
screen you've got the bottom
bar, very creatively named here,
the bottom bar, top bar.
And you'll see that in the
bottom bar you've got the
action items, which have now
moved down there, along with
trailing off into the overflow
menu, rather than being at the
top right there, in the
main action bar.
ROMAN: A couple more points
on the screen.
You'll notice that the concept
of navigation versus action,
the separation of the two,
is still in play.
Except that spatially it's
no longer horizontal.
It's purely vertical.
At the top you have all of your
navigational affordances
and elements.
And at the very bottom you
have your actions.
So that pattern is still
kept in check.
The other thing I want to
mention was actually on the
previous screen.
Not only is the scalability, the
stretchiness of the action
bar important on different
devices, but you'll also
notice that on tablets the
action bar is actually
slightly taller.
The app icon is displayed
slightly larger.
And the action bar buttons
are slightly wider.
So an action bar button
on the a may be
something like 56 dps.
Wide.
On a tablet, I think
it's about 64 dps.
And the action bar height, I
think it's something like 48.
And then on tablets it's 56,
or something like that.
But again, this stuff
may change.
So just using the standard
action bar gives you
all this for free.
ADAM: And if potentially some
huge tablet comes out in the
future, or something like that,
the action bar may have
a different size again, a
different way of formatting.
But as long as you stick to
using action bar, your
application should still look
and display fine here.
ROMAN: One more [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM: Contextual action bar,
Nick, do you want to discuss
that a little bit?
NICK: Yeah, definitely.
So the contextual action bar is
one of my favorite tricks.
It has the ability transformer
its appearance to give you
contextual actions to whatever
is on screen.
So in this screen shot here we
can see examples of selecting
text or selecting an
email message.
Where the same physical space
animates and rotates around,
and offers alternate actions.
And the contextual action bar
really is a first class
citizen, like the standard
action bar.
And you can still do things
like the split action bar.
So if you have a plethora of
options that you want to have
immediately available on screen,
without having to dip
down into the overflow, you can
go into that split mode,
like the mail app is there.
And show those things
immediately.
And if you want to know more
about contextual action bar,
we actually did a deep dive on
this a couple of months back.
So you can go back through the
archives into the video
messaging contextual
action bar.
ADAM: And it's worth noting that
generally it's engaged by
long pressing on a particular
element of the screen.
So in this example, I think
we have browser,
and Gmail or email.
In some cases, though, there can
be a UI element that you
can touch upon to engage it.
So in this case, in Gmail,
it's a check box.
You can touch that check box.
And the contextual action bar
triggers at that point.
ROMAN: The other important thing
to note about contextual
actual bars is that
conceptually, and logically,
they're a mode.
So when you select, something
you're basically
entering into a UI mode.
And that mode is, something
is selected.
So what happens is, the context
of the screen, the
layout of the screen, doesn't
really change.
For example in Gmail's
case, the list
items are still there.
But the action bar, basically
the Chrome around the content
changes to reflect what
mode you're in.
And then once you cancel out
of that mode by either
pressing the back button or
pressing the check market in
the top left, that
cancels the mode.
That exits the mode.
And then you're back to what
the screen normally was.
So just think of it as
a UI mode, almost.
ADAM: So moving on to the second
portion of the action
bar that we're talking about,
the view controls.
So one possible option
to show there in the
control section are tabs.
And there are two main
categories of tabs.
There's fixed times and
scrollable tabs.
And there's a couple examples
there on the slides
that you can see.
I personally really like fixed
tabs, where they're
appropriate.
Just because it's really, really
quick and easy to flip
between the different views.
Obviously they're only
appropriate when you've got
maybe two, three, maybe four
different views that you want
to flip between.
And obviously you should
always enable swipe to
navigate between those
different tabs.
Then you've also got scrollable
tabs, where you
could potentially have any
number of different views that
you're switching between.
It could be a no number, a bit
larger number than, say the
three or four that fixed
tabs support.
Or it could be an unknown number
that you don't know how
many are going to
trail off there.
So here's an example
from [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN: One thing to note is
that, if you're a developer
and you're trying to implement
this, it's actually called a
page or title strip.
Its a misnomer.
We call them scrollable tabs
on the design side, because
logically, and from a mental
model perspective, they serve
the same purpose as tabs.
It's just from an interaction
standpoint
they're slightly different.
So one of the key difference
is that you don't
see them all at once.
And they are slightly thinner.
So they're not really
a touch target.
They really more an indicator.
But usually they are
coupled with touch.
So in case the user does touch
that area that indicates the
next page or the previous page,
you should still swipe
over or switch over.
ADAM: In terms of how it fits
in the action bar, in that
split action bar mode these
fixed tabs will actually take
up the whole width below the
main action bar, and so will
the scrollable tabs.
But when there's more room,
for example in a landscape
mode or in a tablet, those fixed
tabs can actually fall
in line with the main
action bar.
Whereas those scrollable tabs
really need to take up entire
width of the screen.
NICK: And another option, when
we're talking about the
different bars you have, you can
have your main action bar,
your top bar, and then
the bottom bar.
In some cases, having a top
action bar as well as the
stacked tab bar, there's
[INAUDIBLE] that thinks it's
entirely valid to hide the top
action bar if it's not really
adding anything to your design,
and you want to free
up some more content
are of your apps.
If you take a look at, for
example, of the dialer
application or contacts
applications that ship with
ICS+ devices, you can see that
they've hidden the top action
bar and just had the prefixed
tabs right at the top to free
up some room.
ROMAN: Another example of that,
from the third party
space, is Pinterest.
And I wouldn't say that
they exactly use tabs.
They look and feel like tabs.
You can swipe between them.
And there are three of them.
So they kind of represent
tabs.
They're very similar to the
people app tabs, or such.
But that's another example.
So it's an example of where
the widths aren't equal.
The Home tab in the Pinterest
app is default selected.
So it's a slight variation.
But again, it's a deviation
with a purpose.
They wanted to simplify
things.
I think it's a fairly
good execution.
ADAM: So moving on, view
controls, you can also have
spinners and drawers.
I don't think we're going to
spend too long in here,
because we know there's a lot
of discussion about drawers
still, and the pattern is still
not finalized on the
design side.
But just to quickly mention it,
both of them are ways to
switch between views.
A spinner is a drop down, pop
up dialogue that drops down
from the top of the action
bar, which allows you to
switch between views.
The navigation drawer slides
out from the side.
And the YouTube app is the
main example of how to
implement a navigation at
this point in time.
I don't know.
Do you guys want to mention
anything more about this?
We could probably talk about
drawers versus spinners for
much longer than half an hour.
ROMAN: At a high level,
I'd say looking at
the different options--
tabs, spinner, navigation
drawer--
when you look at these elements,
they're functionally
somewhat equivalent.
There are some minor differences
in terms of when
you should use the spinner
versus navigation drawer, as
well as when it's appropriate
to use tabs versus spinner.
But functionally, they're
lateral navigation elements.
So they let you navigate across
sibling elements, or
sibling screens.
And then it's kind of
interesting to look at the
action bar's navigational
components as both ancestral
navigation and lateral
navigation.
So the Up button, which we made
brief mention of, lets
you accomplish ancestral
navigational, lets you walk up
the structure of an app.
Versus tabs or spinners and
navigation drawers, they let
you navigate laterally across
the structure of your app.
So when you're planning out how
do you design an app that
uses all these different
navigational elements, think
about your app in terms
of the screen map.
Or think about it in terms of
the structure, a tree almost,
a hierarchical structure.
And see where you can introduce
elements to better
convey that structure
to your users.
ADAM: One thing I will quickly
say is I very much dislike it
when a drawer has three
items in it.
Because it could much, much,
much better be represented by
something like regular tabs.
And it gives the user
the on screen
visuals immediately there.
You can swipe int them.
It's just so much easier.
That's one pet peeve of mine.
ROMAN: One of the other things,
since we're on the
topic of tabs--
ADAM: I knew we were going
to get stuck on this.
ROMAN: Tabs are important.
One of the things that's
different between Android and
other platforms is tabs
aren't persistent.
So this is one thing that I
have seen some folks get
caught up with.
They keep tabs visible
throughout the entire app.
So the action bar is really
the one thing that should
really be present throughout
the entire app.
Because it gives you access to
the Up button, as well as
things like settings,
and whatnot.
But tabs are really a per
screen type thing.
So if your top level screen has
tabs, once you get into a
detail screen from within one of
those tabs-- let's say you
touch a list item in tab one--
you should hide those tabs.
And then to get back to those
tabs, the user should press Up
to get to the top level screen
that has those tabs.
So that's one thing to make
sure that you don't do, is
have hierarchy and history
within a tab.
A tab is really just a segment
of the screen, almost.
ADAM: Yeah.
The action bar is the anchor
of the application.
It should be visible
all the time.
And the other elements should
come and go as needed.
Let's get on, get away from
this before we get stuck.
Action buttons, Nick,
do you want to?
NICK: Yeah, so action buttons
are the right hand section of
the action bar, which allow you
to perform actions which
are contextual to the
content on screen.
And we use this FIT rule, which
you can see on screen
here, to determine which actions
should appear front
and center right on the action
bar, and which ones are less
important, and should
be tucked away under
the overflow menu.
So the FIT scheme, it refers
to something which is
Frequently Important
or Typical.
So just some examples,
frequently in an imaging
application, like the gallery,
for example, you frequently
want to share that.
So we have the Share action
button right, front and center
in the action bar.
So it's very easy
to achieve that.
Something which is important,
say in an email application we
have the Send button
in the action bar.
Its right there at the top
of the screen as the most
important thing.
And one more thing, if there
is one single, the most
important action on the screen,
try and keep it to the
leftmost action.
Because that's more likely to
be shown on action bar, and
not tucked away under the
overflow if there isn't
sufficient room.
And last of the rules
is Typical.
So something like Search, as we
touched on slightly earlier
on, you're going to always look
to the top right to look
for the search action.
Because it's typically
found there.
So you would want to
follow that rule.
And one thing I'd just like
to clarify is [INAUDIBLE]
we've called it out on the
bottom, saying that items in
the action bar need to be
unambiguous as to what they're
going to apply to.
So, if there's something like
an Edit action in the action
bar, but there's actually a
couple distinct groups of
content on the screen so it's
unclear, you want to put that
action in line in the
content area, so
that there's no ambiguity.
You want to either do that in
line, or you could perhaps use
the contextual action bar in
that instance, to enable some
modes then to perform the action
on an individual piece
of content.
And the other thing we want to
call out here is to really try
and reuse people's mental
models, these common, very
well established actions.
Something like Search or Edit
or Share has these very well
known glyphs associated
with these actions.
So you want to be using the
platform default ones.
So take a look at the--
there's a download on the design
side, the action bar
download pack, as well as
they'll bring in assets
studio, which will help you to
find or slightly hint these
icons to your [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN: The other very minor
thing on that is that don't
feel that you're restricted
to use the styling--
holo dark or holo light
styling-- for
the action bar buttons.
If you have a very, very branded
action bar, or very
branded app in general that
has its own color scheme,
maybe even some minor visual
effects here and there, as
long as you use the
core iconography--
and the core iconography you can
get with the Illustrator
files that come with
that download--
just apply your styling on top
of those Illustrator files.
So that you still use the same
iconography, not necessarily
the same styling.
ADAM: And one last thing I just
wanted to mention was
don't feel like you have to put
actions necessarily in the
action bar.
You can put them in
line as well.
That's definitely an
alternate option.
If it's relevant to the content,
or it fits better
with the flow of the screen,
you could possibly put
something in line.
It's definitely another
option.
But if that's not what you want,
if you want to stick to
the standard pattern, put
them in the action bar.
All right.
NICK: So you touched on this
earlier on as well.
You're not actually
saying this item
must, must, must show.
I think the whole point of the
action bar is it really helps
you to build on this responsive
design technique
that we're always
talking about.
Android is designed to scale.
And you don't necessarily know
at design time how wide they
device is going to be which
your app is running on.
Is it in landscape?
Is it in portrait?
Is it a tablet sized device?
So the action bar is really
build with in its
underpinnings.
And so the way you define your
actions, you actually can say
this should always show up in
action bar, and never go under
the overflow menu.
Or conversely, never.
So something like settings, you
would say, never show this
as a front and center action.
Pop this on the overflow.
And the last one, the most
interesting one you probably
want to use for most
of your actions is
just to say, if room.
So what that'll say is,
if there's room,
please display this.
And otherwise tuck it under.
And the system will go through
in the order in which you
defined your actions, and try
and show as many as it can.
And any it doesn't have
room for will get
tucked under the overflow.
So you really want to be
thinking about your actions.
And say, something like an email
application, Send should
always be on the screen.
But these other things
are less important.
And they can go underneath
the overflow if need be.
And so, don't get hung up on
thinking, these two things are
always going to be
on the screen.
These things are always going
to be off screen.
Try and work with the if room,
and try and have this kind of
stretchable design if you can.
ADAM: I really like this.
Because it forces you to think
about the FIT pattern that we
were talking about before, and
just really prioritize which
actions you think are
most important.
If a user has the Nexus S, and
they can only fit two items up
there, you're always going to
have the two items you think
are the most importantly
visible to the user.
So I think I think it's
a good way of
decluttering your UI, almost.
It forces you to tackle that
problem, rather than just say
I'll throw everything on the
screen, and hope the user can
work out what's happening.
All right, we better get
moving here, guys.
ROMAN: So I'll just quickly
jump through
key styles for branding.
So you've seen this through
our various designs
throughout the show.
But the key things you should
think about when styling the
action bar, outside of just
picking color schemes, you can
obviously apply patterns, or
subtle gradients, and just
solid colors to these.
You should really be thinking
about the action bar's core
background.
That's the number one way
you can brand things.
If you're Yahoo!, it should
probably be purple, or
something like that.
For the stacked bar background,
you probably want
to use a very similar shade,
or a similar hue, but a
slightly darker or slightly
lighter version.
The reason you don't want to
do something too crazy is
that, again, in landscape, your
tabs can actually stack
up into the top bar.
And so the tabs may not have
enough contrast if there's a
completely different color
palette between the action bar
background and its
stack background.
You could probably make
it work through some
tricks here and there.
But it's generally easiest
if you just make a slight
variation to the background
for the stacked top bar.
Also the selected tab strip,
that's where you can really
show your brand's accent color,
if you have a secondary
color in your palette, as well
as the press state background.
So that's definitely something
to keep in mind.
If your action bar background
is blue, the default press
state background for
the action bar is
also going to be blue.
If you touch an icon, or if you
touch the Up button, it's
going to be blue background.
So the contrast may
not be very good.
So make sure to tweak that,
and to account for that.
NICK: For developers, there's
an article on the Android
developers blog on how to
achieve these styling
techniques.
ROMAN: What was it?
j.mp/customizingactionbar?
I think you just search for Nick
Butcher customizing the
action bar, you'll get that.
NICK: I forget.
ROMAN: Then there's the really
awesome action bar style
generator tool for developers,
that you can basically just
create all the assets you need
right from this tool.
Really awesome tool.
We use it in a lot
of our samples.
ADAM: There's an additional
style, called action bar
overlay style that you can use
if, say the content is just so
important in this particular
screen, you can really make
the action bar and system
Chrome fade out
a little bit here.
So there's two examples here.
One is Google Maps, on
the right there.
And you can see the map is,
obviously, just the most
important thing within an
application like Google Maps.
And so you can see it's
transparent, allowing the map
to bleed through a
little bit there.
It looks really, really nice.
And then the system gallery is
another great example, which
we're using right now.
And one thing you should do is
if, something like gallery,
where you the user may want to
see the picture without any
other Chrome visible, touching
the screen should really make
the actual bar come on screen,
then disappear again--
ROMAN: Along with
the status bar.
ADAM: And potentially the status
bar as well, and the
system controls on the bottom.
That's not really possible with
something like photo viewing.
But with video viewing, you can
actually make the entire
thing go full screen.
ROMAN: And for developers out
there, there's a template that
you can use with Eclipse.
If you do File, New, and then
Android Object, you can choose
full screen activity.
And it gives you all
this for free.
ADAM: Cool.
OK, we've got to move along.
ROMAN: Yes, let's cut through.
ADAM: Custom action views,
Nick, do you want to--?
Very quick.
NICK: Yeah, sure.
ADAM: You've got five words.
NICK: [INAUDIBLE] don't just
have to be just buttons.
They can be a little bit
more interactive and
response than that.
So here's a few examples
of the stock ones.
So you have a common pattern is
to transform a refresh icon
into an indeterminate
progress spinner.
So you can use the same space
to indicate progress or
inaction, which is great.
Another common one is the
such an action provider.
So this is a way to, when you
click on a search action, have
it expand out, take over the
action bar's physical space,
similar to how the contextual
action bar will, in order to
provide the search affordance,
which is a great [INAUDIBLE].
And the last one we've
got out here is the
Share action provider.
This is an excellent way of
providing a ordered list of
the way [INAUDIBLE]
share.
So if I always go to a certain
couple of apps, they'll
actually float to the
top of the list.
And in fact, the most commonly
used app to share that certain
media type will be [INAUDIBLE]
in action bar.
So it's easy.
So you have this richer behavior
from the action
buttons, not just
simple buttons.
ADAM: Cool, excellent.
And I think Nick was talking
about this briefly before.
But some devices still have
a hard menu button.
And so in that case, the
overflow menu actually doesn't
show in action bar.
And instead, when you hit the
device hard menu, or legacy
menu button, the additional
overflow items will pop up
from the bottom.
So you can see that here on the
Nexus S, versus the Nexus
4, where the overflow
menu still pops
up those same options.
Not going to--
just keep--
[INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN: Lastly--
NICK: You don't have to do
anything to get this behavior.
That comes for free from the
system to use the native
action bar.
ROMAN: And lastly,
Done and Discard.
This is something that's
not yet documented.
I think we'll probably be
documenting it in the future.
But as an alternative, if you
have a really, really simple
screen, like for example like
just a single edit screen, or
something, and you really only
have two things you can do--
either Save or Cancel--
and you don't want to
use a dialogue.
Because generally, you want
to avoid dialogues.
You want to avoid the extra
burden on the user to think
about what else is around
the screen.
You can use the done slash
discard pattern, where instead
of an action bar, instead of
the Up button, instead of a
title and overflow,
you just show two
actions, Done and Discard.
And there's, again positive
button on the right, negative
but on the left.
Alternatively, if discarding is
not really that common, or
if you have other actions you
need to show, you can just
show Done in the top left,
which takes the
place of the Up button.
And that's like the same thing
as saying, if I press this I
have the added confidence that
when I go up, or when I leave
this context, I'm actually
persisting
my content, my changes.
So that's just an alternative
that you can use for very
simple screens.
ADAM: Cool.
And then design news, we're
going to have to--
ROMAN AND ADAM: Fly
through it.
ROMAN: This is from the
developer of I think it was a
carbon for Android.
He had a bunch of thoughts on
holo, and what it means.
What is the language?
As a designer, are
you using it?
Or you are you elaborating
on it?
So just a couple of thoughts
here as a Google+ post.
Definitely worth reading if
you're designing for Android.
NICK: And lastly here is a
regular contributor, Marie
[INAUDIBLE]
has given a great walkthrough
of her mental processes she
goes through, the workflow she
goes through when she's
designing an application.
So you don't drive straight
into your pixel
editing tool of choice.
But she walk through the
concepting behind it, and
thinking about the information
hierarchy.
And this post is really,
really great.
And it's a good insight into
how other people work.
ROMAN: Cool.
ADAM: And we're done.
ROMAN: Yeah, with that, thanks
again for joining us here on
Android Design in Action, where
we talked about the
action bar, everything
you needed to know.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM: Adam [INAUDIBLE].
NICK: Nick Butcher.
ADAM: See you guys.
ROMAN: See you next
week, or whatever.
See you guys, bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]